oh move
you can't see us if we don't move if you
sit still it's not going to see you
complete joke supposedly it becomes down
to the t-rex's brain shape is similar to
that of frogs and frogs can only see
movement frogs can't only see movement
otherwise they wouldn't be able to
function hi i'm dr dave hohn i'm a
paleontologist at queen mary university
of london i'm an expert on dinosaur
behaviour and ecology today we're going
to be looking at some dinosaur and
pterosaur clips from movies and tv and
judge how real they
are put 12 amps in these animals they're
never gonna trust me again he's giving
them supposedly the stop signal but
they're still coming for him if you tell
a dog to stop it should stop pretty much
instantly if it keeps coming and it
keeps growling it's not responding to
that signal so velociraptor's tiny it
would be waist high to him standing up
so these are grossly exaggerated in
terms of their size we now know they're
fully feathered they would be as
feathered as modern birds these things
should be totally covered in feathers
their heads are really big and blocky
velociraptors got a really long narrow
skull so i think kind of you know
doberman shaped head which these really
don't have back up
the noises are a bit mixed they're using
various different things so i think
there's geese in there and some
alligator hisses they didn't have super
complicated voice boxes like modern
birds do so they're probably not making
really complicated trills and whistles
and things like that crocodiles are the
nearest living relatives to dinosaurs
apart from birds which really are
dinosaurs and they have actually quite a
range of calls and
growls and there's no reason to think
they wouldn't sound something like that
they're much heavier than you they're
much stronger than you they're much
faster than you they can jump far higher
than you can they don't seem to climb
oddly when we think they in reality they
probably could by climbing up a tree
that's probably quite a good strategy if
you can get up the tree fast enough
before they can get to you
they're basically just going up and down
like those really old movies of people
trying to build airplanes in like 1910
and the wings just flap up and down and
the whole machine just bubbles and then
falls apart and if you do that you push
air down to go up and then you
immediately push air up and go down and
all you'll do is bob around on space
that's how they're trying to fly you
need to fold the wing for the upstroke
and then open it up for the downstroke
[Music]
she just grabbed someone and picked them
up pterosaurs feet are built just like
ours they have a really big long flat
bit of the main part of the foot and
then some very small toes at the edge
and yeah if you've tried picking a pen
up with your toes it's really quite hard
and this is a you know trope from
dinosaur films there's nothing to grip
with
your next problem is a pteranodon of
about that size weighs 30 40 kilos and
it's lifting up a human who's
60 70. so you wouldn't be able to grab
anyone
this bit's nice we don't know if
pterosaurs could dive it's certainly
possible that they could pelicans are
famous for doing this sort of thing it's
really motoring like
like penguins don't move that quick
underwater
the mosasaur model is really nice it's
way too big like it's about double the
size that it should be i mean certainly
10 12 meters this thing's like 20 plus
but one thing you can just see though
which is really nice is the palatal
teeth they don't just have teeth around
the edge of the mouth they actually have
more teeth fixed into the roof of the
mouth and you can see them there they
eat pterosaurs they eat fish they eat
sharks they eat other marine reptiles
they eat turtles all of this kind of
stuff but the dinosaur's about a five
the mosasaur is like seriously like an
eight or a nine apart from just being
way too big
one herd had only a single baby
that's about the right shape for a
dinosaur egg they're not classically hen
shaped with the really big bulbs they're
actually more elongated and oval so they
got that right their last hope for the
future that's a slight worry already
where they say they had one baby and
that's their hope for the future i don't
know how you're going to keep a herd
going with one we have dinosaur nests
with adults on them and embryos in the
eggs that match the adults on the nest
40 50 eggs is pretty normal
i don't think we have any sauropod
embryos so we don't have any
like immediately post-hatching animals
it would have a bit of a longer neck and
a bit of a longer tail than this but it
is really nice that it's not just an
adult made smaller all the babies don't
just look like the adults they look like
juvenile versions they've got those
classic baby things which is not just
true of humans and things like puppies
relatively big eyes in a relatively big
head and relatively big feet this is
really really normal when we find eggs
they're often broken like this in the
end they shatter into lots and lots of
little pieces until recently we only had
dinosaur eggs that were relatively hard
and bird-like and we've now started
finding some that were more reptile-like
which probably explains why we hadn't
found them before because they're rather
more fragile and they don't preserve
very well he knew them by sight
by scent
and by their love
he knew they would be together always we
do have herds of sauropods it's
perfectly reasonable that juveniles
would hang around the whole time but we
also don't know we see cohort separation
in others so in other words the babies
all hatch they grow to a certain size
and then they'll go off on their own
dinosaurs part of a group called
archosaurs which includes
modern birds which are dinosaurs and
crocodiles basically
almost all of them exhibit what we call
both pre and post-hatching parental care
so yeah they would recognize their
parent they would follow them around and
the parent would look after them they're
probably going to separate off at some
point or at least in certain cases we
see that we find groups of dinosaurs all
of one age and then groups of another of
one species and then another group and
then another group and another group oh
like an eight it's really good
the series they call this an acer
wrapped up as far as i know it's made up
it's really nice that the crest itself
is brightly coloured it's a display
structure that's the one bit that it's
trying to show off with that should be
the colourful bit not the rest of it
there are dinosaurs with
attacking tails you've got things like
ankylosaurus with their armored
dinosaurs they're famous tail clubs
stegosaurs with their spikes on the end
of the tail so stigurus it would be
doing some kind of cutting action rather
than an impaling or crushing one because
it's got a big series of serrated
cutting edges on the end of it
this super long thin whiplash tail and
it's been suggested that that would be
very nasty if it hit something i think
the bones would shatter if it did it's
an impact it's like being slapped with
something it's not cutting you because
there's no edge there it's a
circular cross section of some muscle
around bone it's not gonna cut you in
half and so you're gonna run up to
something and then stop and turn around
and hit it with your tail
this is not a good way of catching
something and if it's running away if
you're trying to run after it and then
stop and turn up and hit it with your
tail how would it ever evolve six five
five
is tiny
they're big animals two and a half plus
meters tall to the top of the head it'll
be at the ceiling of the room we're in
now the crests are really good they come
up and over in this arc but you can't
quite see it now but there's also this
little spike that extends off the rear
this is what you'd expect from an animal
that hadn't encountered people before
this is an animal in a zoo with keepers
it has encountered people before
there's no reason to think that it had
that whatsoever it's got a big display
feature on its head why has it got
another one this is copied off uh i
think of the thrilled lizard in
australia which absolutely does have
this big fan that it puffs out
this is it's uh spitting what's supposed
to be some kind of venom at him i
believe it's just supposed to be kind of
toxic saliva
there are lots of reptiles that have a
pretty toxic saliva in addition to like
specialized venom in the way that we see
in snakes but that looks like goo
that's horrible stuff it's not going to
kill you instantly toxins take time to
work you want to get it into the system
that's why you want to bite if you're
venomous and it's not doing that
they apparently had to string a
guesthouse string under the dashboard of
the car and they were plinking it and
that's what makes the little red pores
in the thing um big animals
obviously are heavy um but they don't
tend to shake things very much elephants
are famous for moving around very
quietly we walk in environments that are
very hard that we have built rock
doesn't tend to vibrate like that and
soils of all different kinds give so big
animals don't
leave earth shaking footstep if the
t-rex was running down the road yeah i'd
expect that but it walking around still
in its enclosure it's not going to be
shaking
the ground
it looks like a t-rex gone wrong it's a
head shape it's weird it's kind of got a
white of the eye which of course animals
don't usually have and it looks like
it's got three fingers whereas if it's
supposed to be a tyrannosaur at least a
t-rex it should only have two don't move
you can't see us if we don't move if you
sit still it's not going to see you
complete joke supposedly it becomes down
to the t-rex's brain shape is similar to
that of frogs and frogs can only see
movement frogs can't only see movement
otherwise they wouldn't be able to
function what they're very good at is
seeing things that move which is a
different thing entirely frogs can
absolutely see things that don't move
t-rex doesn't have the brain of a frog
and therefore if you combine those two
it almost certainly could see you on top
of that t-rex has arguably the biggest
eyeball of any terrestrial animal of all
time the idea that it had poor eyesight
is beyond a myth it's the absolute
opposite it's arguably the best eyesight
of any terrestrial animal of all time
[Music]
the bit where they wave the flare and
throw it i'd absolutely sure it would be
very interested in that and if it sees
that flying over it's going to be more
interested than that than you standing
still but just holding the kids going
don't move
that gets you eaten but it's not
terrible it's just a bit clunky
traveling in a group like this pretty
much not unless
something is driving it like a drought
and we absolutely have fossil beds where
the
evidence from the geology suggests that
there have been a massive drought
followed by a massive flood and yet
pretty much every dinosaur in the
environment is preserved together
because
this was probably the last remaining bit
of water that draws every animal in
carnosoros is part of this really weird
group called a belly source you see
these tiny tiny tiny little mitteny
hands
everyone jokes about t-rex and it's tiny
has got nothing on your belly sores the
little armor spikes down the side maybe
sometimes you do get thick scales like
that but the jaw shape is absolutely
spot-on
this is the absolute cliche behavior of
every predator in every documentary and
movie ever
why attack someone when you can stop
roar at them first to scare them off and
then run after them lions don't sneak up
behind buffalo raw and then attack
facing them down some animals do this
this is how elephants respond to lions
is how buffalo respond to lion it's
certainly been hypothesized that a bunch
of dinosaurs did this you can see it's
got these kind of spiky thumbs which
have been suggested to be used to fight
off predators but as you can see in this
kind of situation he might poke a couple
of holes in him before his head gets
ripped off
the idea that carnivores are aggressive
and herbivores are passive is a joke if
you go to africa the thing that most
people are worried about are things like
elephants and buffalo and kate buffalo
in particular are extraordinarily
dangerous animals hippos are famously
very dangerous herbivores are not just
peaceful gentle giants the situation is
obviously a bit weird but fundamentally
the anatomy of the dinosaurs is great
this is a 9.
if it's supposed to be a giganotosaurus
someone's accidentally copied t-rex and
just given it three fingers that doesn't
make it giganotosaurus the head shape's
completely wrong for that
they're very big and heavy so they're
not going to be that fast 10 15 miles an
hour more than fast enough to outrun him
these were basically marathon runners
they're also never going to be able to
hide and ambush something over a short
distance they're going to you know come
over the horizon or come out the trees
the prey is going to see them coming and
bolt and they're just going to go and
keep going and keep going and keep going
they had adaptations in their feet to
basically retain energy with each step
and make it make themselves good for
that the proportions of
the various bones down the leg make them
good for taking lots of steps
with a long stride length
they're not that quick at turning i
think your best bet would be to try and
spiral what i'd want to find is a really
big tree or a really big rock formation
and just go around that until they got
bored and lost interest but they might
still be able to keep going longer than
you can
if it's supposed to be a giganotosaurus
about a
[Applause]
so we've got carnotaurus again big
reptile-like scales that overlap which
is not what dinosaurs have
kind of classic floppy over hands which
now every dinosaur has to have because
of course they copied it off jurassic
park and for the velociraptors they had
human puppets with people in them and
our arms don't flex that way but we can
do this effectively so at least part of
the reason that the velociraptor hands
do that in jurassic park is because
there's a human inside them controlling
the arms but then of course absolutely
everyone copies that and so now all
dinosaurs have this dreadful hand
pasture
i mean that would probably have a
decent effect a taser is just putting
lots of electricity through you and that
messes up your nerves and stops you
doing anything and dinosaurs had nerves
operating in the same way that ours do
why these people are so hilariously
underequipped zoos carry elephant guns
or rifles capable of tackling things
like lions or they have
the police unnoticed nearby who can come
out at very very short notice yet
another five i think
this is the big kind of t-rex equivalent
taking on from the t-rex that was in the
original 1933 king kong what are they
called is it vastatasaurus they call it
or something like that
and the movement's right the feet move
right they come down you get the you get
the lift off and the the toes come
together and then spread again um it's
got the uh the slight leg swing which is
really nice they always tend to make
them run like this and they want to be
placing the feet in the midline so the
legs should swing in with each step and
they kind of have that going here
there's not a lot of point chasing for a
much smaller bit of food while you're
carrying a giant bit of food in your
mouth for a fictional
hyper-evolved
tyrannosaur it's really nice yeah i'd
give it a
9.
the spinosaurus it's not bad for the
time so this was yeah 2001. spinosaurus
was a was an extremely poorly known
dinosaur we had a bunch of fragmentary
fossils the best of which had been
destroyed in world war ii by an allied
bombing raid some recent discoveries
from morocco have restored some of those
gaps we now know it it probably wasn't
quite as tall as this it had rather
short legs it had a rather thin like
tail the spine on the back probably
looked somewhat like this but it wasn't
just this perfect kind of semi-circle
big carnivores do and will fight and
kill each other but again it's a really
terrible idea you're facing an animal
equally sized to you equally well armed
as you and you don't know who's going to
win and it might be neither of you why
would you bother to have this fight
now that's probably fatal t-rex has like
the biggest bite power of anything we've
ever seen big teeth they're about this
white an inch and a half wide and maybe
five six inches long
we have
big bones
bitten through by
adult t-rexes and it's just bitten
through the base of the neck so you've
got your
trachea and your esophagus so the
windpipe has just been crushed by the
lower jaw it's esophagus has been
severed vagus nerve and then the upper
jaw is coming in through the top that
almost certainly severing the spinal
cord
head butt smash that's been suggested
for tyrannosaurs they do have these
thick armor across the top of the head
certainly possible and then that like
the spiders just like snaps its neck
they don't have anything like the neck
and jaw power for that and t-rex has an
absolute bull net because it's got such
a big heavy head it has a really short
very muscular neck there's one dinosaur
you probably can't do that to it's it's
him i
refuse on principle to answer the
question who would win in a fight
between because i think it is the most
trite boring and uninteresting thing
that one could possibly say about
dinosaurs even in fiction but it's t-rex
i'd actually give it and i really quite
like this bit
wonderful internal consistency because
this is supposedly a mixture from
indominus rex from the last film and a
velociraptor except indominus rex was a
mixture of velociraptor so it's a
mixture of velociraptor and velociraptor
some organisms are surprisingly
resilient to having their genes tinkered
with most famously plant all kinds of
different plants hybridized rampantly
with things that are
so far evolutionary from them the
entertaining bit the geneticist in the
jurassic world series is that they're
simultaneously geniuses because they can
produce animals like this that function
whilst incompetent where they somehow
managed to imbue them with incredible
traits without having known about it we
accidentally gave it cuttlefish
camouflage powers but we didn't know
the first thing we should say is that
he's certainly done nothing or killed
this dosing an animal with an anesthetic
is extremely difficult and you need to
really know the physiology of the animal
and you need to know how heavy it is
they're hooked inwards which makes no
sense at all animals have teeth that
curve backwards so that when they bite
on something they're hooking in and the
animal can't pull out but they're going
this way
that's a big animal that's absolutely
got the strength to lift someone up like
that your bones and your ligaments and
tendons are really quite strong it's
fairly hard to actually remove things
like arms you go into a cage with a big
predator that you don't know if it's
unconscious and start pulling in its
mouth yeah three but yeah disney's
dinosaur is really quite good the one i
always say is actually jurassic park
three because it's got the most amount
of dinosaurs in it and the fewest number
of annoying children in it which is a
real bonus for a jurassic park film
thanks for watching if you want to watch
more videos like this please follow the
links above